[موسيقى]
ويضع السقرون في مصر الاتفاقيات الدوليه
لحمايه الحيوانات المهدده بالانقراض نصف
اعينهم كما هو الحال مع هذا الصقر الذي
وصل لمصر المصابه من المجر فالتقته
الصقارون وعالجه وهاهم يطلقونه مره اخرى
ليكمل رحلته خطوه تظهر محافظه صقار مصر
على الصقور وحمايتها بالنسبه لنا احنا
دايما في تعاون مع وزاره البيئه
احنا
بنبدا بنساعد الوزاره في ان اي طيور
بتتمسك احنا بنحاول ان احنا بنشتريها خلاص
كده خلينا صادقين مع بعض احنا بنشتريها من
فلوسنا وبنبدا ان احنا نعمل لها اعاده
تاهيل الطيور اللي بينفع انها تطلق الطيور
ما ينفعش انك تطلب يحصل لها عمليه تبني زي
معنا
اليوتيوب مش هينفع انها تطلب ثاني انا غير
قادر على التعامل مع البيئه
انما هي المشاكل بتبقى مع الصيادين